the most humiliating Darkest Day of My
Life is
Like
accentuated by my ex showing
up she like comes up to me cuz I didn't
respond and she's like I see you and I'm
like Oh my
[__] God so then yeah so that yeah so
there you go there hey good
[Music]
prompt welcome back to a very compelling
episode of careful boys over there we
got Anthony Steve Green Joe on this side
we got Bart Tyler and Nick and then here
we have myself and
dri all right in your entire creative
career what is the wackest thing you
ever made oh [__] can't even tell you
how much time you whack is so many oh
[__] the thing where if we pulled it up
and showed the audience you guys would
be like no and then like try to hit the
x wait ignore your creative career
though ignore in in all your creative I
was like wait how do I I feel like all
the [__] in the very beginning that I
created of everything that I got into
was cringy it has to be yeah it's like a
Birthright it's like a passage wave the
first couple years on YouTube you just
[__] suck sometimes you have some
actual misses where the thing you made
was never the true intention so you
didn't actually get your intended
product out you know because of whatever
circumstances is there anything that you
made that you're like oh that's a bad
representation of me like I didn't want
to make that okay I'm going to tell you
guys a story right now and I'm I'm going
to hate myself later for tell you
yeah I've somehow avoided letting you
guys know about this but it's okay we're
all Brothers now we have tattoos
together
so so can't go back years ago years
years and years ago I did improv in San
Diego and when I was doing in provin San
Diego I met a bunch of people bunch of
wonderful people met also someone who
was moving to LA and at the time I was
coming up pretty good on YouTube and
stuff like that and then this person was
trying to like make a channel on the
tubes and and they asked me for a favor
and they were like hey would you come
and do my music video and I was like
sure what is it and then they're like
all right so it's like a video game
parody thing of like the Bobble Bubble
Bobble thing the video game yeah yeah
yeah good game right yeah so
so so then I I I basically you know dude
I was so busy at the time that like I
just was like okay I got to be there at
this time and then I'll figure out what
the [__] is going on with the shoot so
once I get there I realize that they're
going to paint me like in blue paint and
like put me in a [__] blue dinosaur
costume and like that like I have to do
like the most embarrassing [__] music
video of my life and it's still like if
Nick if I if Nikki was here right now
she would basically be
howling cuz she knows how much I hate
this [__] video and it's still up
it's still up definitely definitely come
on let's hear it go for it can people
tell that you're the dinosaur oh you
can't miss my [__] sad
eyes you can't miss my S what do I type
okay I'm going to say um Bubble Bobble
parody Steve Green definitely they put
that in there in the terms they put your
name on it definitely dude to try to oh
my God yeah it's there you're in the
first shot in the very first frame oh no
so this is so by the way before you
watch
this so this is you're basically a I
hope you guys feel good about yourselves
you're about to watch a man be graped on
camera essentially in a way because I
was doing a favorite for a friend and
then when I showed up to the shoot it
was much different than I thought but
are you wearing ey Shadow to try to be a
good person is anyone surprised that I'm
a [__] writer no nobody's surprised
that I'm a writer if I say I'll do
something I will do it and this was the
the darkest moment of that you're
wearing eyes
Shadow I don't know what I'm wearing
who's that that's the girl why are you
like [__] boy like face she's the
artist this is a weird Recreation of the
beat what's happening
exactly what the this ISS nothing with
the original beat sounds like it's not
too much Preamble bub Bubble Bubble but
turn her around what's being told to you
in the direction during these moments
we're doing rap
video it hurts me so bad especially
produced on R
man what's happening what the [__]
what the [__] did I tell you did I tell
you you are a rider I'm a rider I'm a
rider it's my least favorite quality by
myself you are a good friend I don't
know what you guys are talking about
this looks like art to
me
honestly you had words you had lines you
had to learn that on the spot yeah wait
was that someone else's words and you
just had to lip sync it why did they use
the original
guy oh my God Steve oh my God Steve
you're a good friend I'm a rider dud
wait they told you to eat ice cream my
worst who's the yeah who's these guys
what are they doing are you at like E3
or something I wasn't there this was a
different location bit this is I was at
the um so good I need to finish it so
wait you guys want to know the worst
part of the story here's the worst part
it kind of just repeat the story gets
worse right oh no so the worst part of
the story right drinking me and my
ex-girlfriend right we had broken up I
want to say [__]
probably like um year and a half before
this and then I started coming up on on
the tubes on tube land right and then
she um oh yeah she showed up at the
place cuz she was doing a show with Dan
Harmon who's like the big um she she
ended up getting married to that guy
right so then like she was like
basically I think dating Dan Haron and
then she shows up cuz she was going to
do this um to this comedy club like
where they hosted Dan harman's show and
she was on his show so then she like
sees me
outside and she's like I'm pretty sure
it's you and she texts me hey are you
outside of like Atomic Comics while
you're in that outfit while I'm in this
outfit and I'm like oh [__] it's hard to
miss me I'm 6'4 but also I'm in a blue
paint in a [__] blue dinosaur costume
everyone sees me on Hollywood Boulevard
oh so then yeah so then the most
humiliating darkest day of my life is
like [__]
accentuated by my ex showing up
and being like
it's well he wasn't there yet still a
little heartbroken a bit she like comes
up to me cuz I didn't respond and she's
like I see you and I'm like oh my
[__] god so then yeah so that yeah so
there you go there hey good prompt good
prompt Shar dude I hey I might as well
do it before one of you guys finds it
anyway but can't believe I just never
I'm a rider I know that you'll ride but
like this is is really writing dude yeah
I told you it's the worst my least
favorite thing about me at least there's
only 16,000 views well there used to be
watch this shit's going to go all over
make it
viral blow it up blow it up blow it I
said fans if we ever asked you for
anything no offense to the girl honestly
it's just I did not know what I was
signing up for and I was just so busy at
the time that I just didn't like read it
all and stuff oh so she did try to tell
you I don't know I don't remember it's
like these guys talk about emails I'm
like I don't what year was that video
uplo I'll Be There was you're good
friend yeah you're you're a writer bro
2013 that felt very 2013 honestly 10
years ago dang dude so yeah that's
definitely that's definitely the doozy
of them all dooy of them all I think
mine might be at least the footage isn't
like my footage is a little bit more
embarrassing I think what is it what are
we talking about cuz it was the first
and last time I ever acted in a future
film and that's your most embarrassing
moment what is this like the smos movie
or the [__] this is the brown movie
oh that's great Chris Brown that's good
that's good see um this hold before we
talk about this this this is the first
this is will be the first last time we
talk about this uh don't say that in
this room buddy yeah this is it might
become your
identity okay real quick hold on hold on
you just you tell it it's so good man
this is your fault by the way because we
were supposed to two other people we
supposed to be the best friends in the
cast and they made me someone else oh
but you did great no I didn't I did why
is it Ryan's fault because we were going
to go in and read for this part of like
these two uh brothers or or best friends
in his Sony film then I was on tour so I
I didn't want to leave tour so he ended
up doing this other role of like the
loose cannon In This Crew the so this is
the movie Battle of the Year oh battle
of the year he plays like the cocky bad
boy and uh but he gets the freaking
Oscar award for this for cocky G boy we
talking
[Music]
bad it's even shot
ridiculous oh
gosh out get him out of
there goab H oh it's Chris
Brown ask you a question what's that
guy's name Josh
yeah I have battle is there enough B he
was better when he was fast
how do you find jce scene he battles
[__] Chris Brown why is Josh back
there why is Josh He Josh's the camera
skip your best
part there he
is that's so
whack tell me if you smell me got
anothering spot
oh
hey back up I got
youever WEA so he keeps interrupting
people's rounds to like go out why is he
like supposed to be the bad guy yeah
well he's just like the Loose Cannon
like he's just not working with the team
you know like the bully kid that thinks
he's all that you're the wver from jail
yeah oh
[__] I didn't know Chris Brown could be
boy like that that's sick
he kills it
too shove Chris Brown D that was a
DQ no more
questions no more questions there's a
joke right look like I'm joking it's
Friday r or somebody's got to go not me
hell no not me coach anyone of them
you'll take your damn pick you are my
bck I said we're breaking into teams but
you didn't become part of a team did you
yeah but I just roasted them coach I
smoke I I I everything out of you is I
you even understand the concept of a
team might be a cliche son but there is
no eye in team there'll be no way in
this team this ain't no team there's a
crew and obviously I'm better than
anyone on it damn Michael Jordan
congratulations damn ego though you got
detention or
something you got kicked off the team a
and I got kicked out of acting I love I
love dialogue where you don't hear the
actor you just hear the [__] writer
being so clever that's that exactly that
okay hear me out how come you don't like
that yeah what's wrong with that
personal opinion was than no no no hear
me out hear me out hear me out this is
the weird part it sounds like that
character would probably have more
scenes like building up to it like you
would know right no one knew who the
[__] that character was so what you just
saw me was the only time I acted in the
film it just R so there's no backstory
that this guy even has an attitude got
heavily cut around what the but did your
ex-girlfriend show up to watch this yeah
no because they left theaters after the
first day that'd be a flex though like
sh movie also has like a 1% on Ron
tomato no no it's got it's got three
children what I what I just shared is
essentially me doing gay porn and
getting nutted all over and then you're
just like hey watch me do this cool
movie we're like I did pretty
good I did what they gave me I did
pretty
good oh dude it actually went up it's
it's 6% it's not the worst it's 6% dude
compared to the other guy you look like
[__] Joe pesy maybe that other guy
was terrible hear me out out your acting
was good the coach was terrible the
writing was bad the character is
supposed to be like the best B boy in
the US right now imagine me walking to
the room and I am literally the worst B
boy in this entire
room real life in real life in real life
so I had I literally apologize before we
started to each bway saying I'm so sorry
I'm so sorry cuz you just recognize them
or or how did you know they're all legit
real they all know each other and those
are Heavy Hitters they like they are
like huge huge cut around like you look
just the same as them yeah but for the
even the person watching it everything
building up to it you have like when did
this guy pop up and when did he have
this thing and the sad part is I legit
thought I killed it was F killed that
[__] did no it was terrible we were at
the screening
Howes let me ask you this oh that was
terrible would you switch spots with me
would you put on the blue paint yeah no
[__] way is more dri so that's more
his thing that's that yeah yeah and you
being a b boy that's more your thing I
would love it but if you had to play
like a serious badass that's I think
that's harder for you cuz you
comedically you know what I mean yeah
sure ultimately like I don't think
Steve's thing is that embarrassing like
as a one time like music video like
situation listen from your generation
you have no right to chime
in no right you guys do so much weird
[__] me and Joe's first five years of
content was all that true it's all true
you guys do so much weird
[__] that's so and by the way I love you
I've had to do something similar though
I had to so I guess my bad one is yeah
okay so I used to do these video game
races and whoever lost would have to do
a challenge so I had to do like all
these challenges all the time cuz I lost
a lot one of them was I had to paint
myself completely purple which didn't
age well cuz it was a really dark purple
uhoh uhoh oh wo and I had pull it up
pull it up getting canel should be there
look at Mario 64 Loser challenge Mario
blackface Mario 64 blackface Loser
Challenge this is definitely probably my
most embarrassing moment the one that
says purple man yeah W this has 240k
views
yeah you can probably just like skip in
a little should I skip anywhere we
already know what era this is this
started off is just the preface of what
it is it's already more engaging you
know Mario 64 versus this is back in
2012 that's you yeah get the [__] out of
here that doesn't look like me now
little moment oh you're heavily backlit
though go go back go back oh my God
Tyler go so this is the come give hug
[Laughter]
skin
Tyler Tyler so you're trying to be
Barney yeah like Barney the
dinosaur oh my
the lighting is so bad Tyler I'm trying
to save you said I'm spam it spam the
brightness wait by going public you
thought
that bro in public you're still [__]
dark bro how dark is that purple okay
that's better it looks better it looks
better now yeah it's not too bad in like
no that's not okay that's not
okay oh my god look that's look go back
go back go hold go back go back see the
bra that was purple that's
purple the bra is purple you are black i
b purple paint your Violet that's a dark
purple that is a dark ass purple the
back back this is my most embarrassing
moment on the internet so look but it
was a success actually you know what it
makes it more embarrassing I don't know
if I trade the blue paint for I think I
keep the blue oh wait never
mind it looks lighter on your arm here
it's the shadow
dude no
oh my God even at this point you still
thought you were
purple this guy's just like I don't care
he's like [__] my [__]
life [__] everything about my life I'm
not going to [__] look at this guy
dude this is before I was ever old
enough to even know what like how it
could be misconstrued it could be bad
that's fair to know about lighting as
well you're old enough to drive you
[__] up I was a gamer I wasn't used to
be on camera that much so dud that's
very fair that's very clear I didn't do
face cam at the time oh hey I'll do it
in front of the like the the the window
that would be
good color correction I was just doing
it in front of my computer screen just
the webcam should we uh let's let's pick
one of these and see uh dude don't look
at any of this I'll tell you this any of
the videos on my Instagram where I'm
talking about anything Fitness related I
want to [__] jump off a you sound
like you hate your your life yeah cuz I
honestly it was at oh actually you know
what David makes fun of me type in this
one type in Nick dun and then type in
chingasos what this is like an old promo
we did like a long time ago and it's
like David always is one where you do
like a a back spin kick and then he go
talk to the camera yeah yeah yeah yeah
dude David [__] wrecks me on this and
it's like every time I watch it anytime
I'm watching anything with me I want to
[__] jump off this is 5 years ago
yeah this is so long ago this is just
such a weird awkward video that we did
to promote like a fight that we had
coming up or something it would just so
go to the end that's where it's way
better dude the end end yeah yeah I
start talking like here yeah a little
little little earlier a little earlier
so I I do a [__] kick and then I turn
to the camera and I start talking wait
go back go back want to see the kick
that's rough that's go back
dude dude you're a Chad you're a
Chad apparently the audio is J what's
with your Audio Level I don't know dude
the audio sucks so the the what the [__]
did you even say dude what did you say
the background music's all the way up
pretty good scoring by the way thanks
dude appreciate it um what does Ching
Goos even mean I think it's a it's like
it means like fist in Spanish something
it was like it was like a David rides
you for only that it was one of the but
I watch it and I'm like dude but you got
to we all got to quiet down and listen
to it honest you really can't hear got
quiet the music quieting down is not the
problem you really
went hey can hey can YouTube subtitles
even pick it up I bet they I bet they
can't they too are like no it's not
available VI is too old rates the
technology what did you say though I
like I don't even remember relatively
cool man yeah that's still kind of cool
this also came after like two really
hard kicks embarrassment is is relative
to the individual isn't it oh shut theck
true sounds like a sex comment cuz even
even when you showed the the blue
[__] dinosaur thing I was like look I
get it it's not that it's not that bad
but I'm sure when you watch it you're
like terrifying bro no his is his is
pretty bad so far thank you I agree
really bad by the wayk by the way thank
you for validating my feelings thank you
we embarassing still pry we probably had
really embarrassing things but we're
proud of it Chris [__] Brown how low
are you getting there Joe like are you
still in the video please don't play any
music or any video of me talking please
I will jump off a bridge I want to play
the video of you talking about TDE n
dude I took that one down a long time
ago I can't find it anymore you ass dud
anytime I'll talk about anything like
that it just sometimes I'll be in the
shower think about it and I'll just like
oh God explain explain it to us so we
know well it's just [__] anytime I'm
talking about anything with like Fitness
or anything I just what's TDE what's up
total daily energy
expenditure what is it dude I don't want
to watch any of this dude any other
questions comments below and I will see
you next time why don't we use this as
our outro for this show oh my God if I
tuck my head on my shirt a turtle yeah
no one can embarrass me scoring still
loud here Andy look not low the score me
if I do this dude too much white someone
cring at themselves so much before yeah
I this isn't even that cringy this is
pretty comments below and I will see
David actually made this one for me he
was he was teaching me how to that's
just you talking like you like you talk
yeah I don't like hearing myself I think
what happens when you watch like show he
has like hair in this video yeah yeah
hella hair my hair's like this dude bar
Juan what's your most embarrassing I
think the whole
Channel that's a good answer that's a
good answer me and Joe are just going
crazy I don't I even know what we're
shooting or anything there's like all
the JK films it's the whole Channel I
choose one video at random and just see
let's see if anything ex what's one
where if we're going to pull it up right
now you're like no no no no no no no
like that kind of [__] and we post it
every week we were in diers BL yeah we
did we did you made sure to run all the
videos by lots of Consultants before
uploading them to YouTube right they
were the
Consultants we consult each other what
do you think it's great upload
it
is